the final trailer for the upcoming third
season of stranger things drops plenty
of hints about the characters journeys
we also get some big clues about the
villains of the season as well as a few
obligatory eighties Easter eggs let's
take a look at the small details you may
have missed the third season of stranger
things will be the first that doesn't
take place during Halloween Netflix
revealed that season 3 will be dropping
on Independence Day 2019 with a special
date announcement and the 4th of July
holiday will also be the setting of the
show this year the final season 3
trailer opens with a wide shot of a
fourth of July fun fair sponsored by
Mayor Cline a new character for season
three Larry Klein is portrayed by Cary
Elwes star of eighties classic The
Princess Bride but in the meantime rest
well promotional materials for the show
describe Kleiner's handsome slick and
sleazy your classic eighties politician
it looks like the mayor will be a
secondary villain of sorts but could his
arc tie into a previously unexplored
plus we're going back to Hawkins in the
summer of 1985 at the height of the Cold
War Theory crafters are predicting that
the duffl return to the Russian spies
subplots planted by journalists turned
private investigator Marie Bowman in
season two one farmer of the Russian
spies in cahoots with the aliens or how
they fit in here doesn't make sense
I closed the gate with that line 11 it's
obviously referring to the moment she
used her psychokinetic powers to steal
the portal to the upside down at the end
of season 2 seemingly saving Hawkins
from the monstrous creatures that dwell
on the other side it didn't take a
genius to figure out that the upside
down would feature in the coming third
season however and the final trailer
confirms that this will indeed be the
case we see 11 in a sense depriving
blindfold early on in the trailer
surrounded by her concerned friends her
trademark nosebleed tells us that she's
using their special abilities and the
following shot shows that she's in the
hellscape that is he upside down
standing in front of a large steelworks
warehouse this warehouse appears to be
the hideout of the evil that will be
unleashed this coming season we see a
swarm of rats converging on the place
and a dark smoked like entity whirling
its way through the empty corridors but
is this entity a new foe or one the
gangers face before inside the brim
Bourn warehouse has a briefer a
mistakable shot of the mind player the
creature that took control of well
buyers in season 2 the young heroes of
Hawkins thought they locked the mind
flare in the upside down but as bias
points out they don't know that for sure
she [ __ ] him in here with us why is as
clearly still connected to the mind
flayer in some way when he drops a huge
clue about the malevolent entities
intentions for season 3 in the last
trailer saying that it'll be looking for
a new host the face of Billy Hargrove
appears on screen as buyers at as the
words heavily implying that the season 2
bully will become an even bigger threat
to the kids at this time out there's an
ominous voice over in the trailer that
has everybody scratching their heads it
begins right at the start of the trailer
playing over some lingering shots of our
tween heroes you lettuce the same voice
can be heard later in the trailer we are
going to end you
we're going and your friends the owner
of the voice has never identified and
there are a lot of theories but listen
closely and the voice sounds an awful
lot like Jacob you see a new addition to
the stranger things cast he's playing a
character called Bruce a reporter from
the Hawkins post who has quotes
questionable morals and a sixth sense of
humor is he going to be an important
villain well put it this way it's
probably no coincidence a beauty's
character shares a name with the shard
from Steven Spielberg's jaws Bruce the
hunters name is my lawyers name I named
the shark after my lawyer he's still my
lawyer by the way we got our first good
look at season 3 newbie Maya Hawke and
the star Court malteaser that Netflix
dropped in July 2018 cork plays a
character named Robin a co-worker of
Steve Hanson at the sparkly new more
scoops ahoy ice cream parlor the first
season 3 trailer showcase Robin in this
capacity but now we know for sure that
she's going to be doing way more than
just scooping ice cream there's a shot
of her pairing through a glass door as
something that's probably not from this
dimension another Burwell during moment
in the trailer is when Stephen Dustin
another canister filled with something
peculiar and judging by what Harrington
is wearing at the time he's in the
middle of a shift at scoops ahoy it's
one of the standout shots from the final
trailer and it seems to indicate that
something is going on in the bowels of
the star Court mall the next two shots
feature people in hazmat suits gathered
around what appears to be some kind of
particle collider the Machine fires up
and shoots a white beam of energy which
could well be the cause of the blackout
at the end of the trailer but who was
experimenting under the mall the Hawkins
National Laboratory was shut down after
it was linked to the death of season 1
fan favorite Barbara Holland though
there are bound to be plenty of other
interested parties when it comes from
locking the secrets of the upside down
there's a lot of quick editing in the
final season 3 trailer but if you watch
it back a couple of times you'll notice
that a few different teams that seem to
have formed by the end 11 Mike and mags
cower together behind the counter while
well Jonathan Nancy and Lucas take cover
behind a battered car Steve Dustin Robin
and Erika appear to escape them all
lastly there are the adults papa Joyce
and Murray Joyce bias had a thing with
Sean Astin's Bob Newby in season two but
the Radio Shack manager was killed
helping the gang escaped
[Music]
Bob wasn't in popular but most stranger
things fans have been shipping a Joyce
hopper relationship since the early days
of the show a blink in your miss it
moment and the final trailer or book
confirms that I'll make the leap in
season three the shot is a close-up of
two unidentified people holding hands
pause there and you'll notice that the
shirts are wearing master ones worn by
choice and hopper earlier in the trailer
David Harbor is aware of how much people
want this and he gets it the fans they
call it like Java or something they'll
ship this relationship of like copper
and Joyce in I do too because I feel
like they're two really lonely lost
people thing
stranger things just wouldn't be
stranger things without all the eighties
Easter eggs and there are going to be
plenty of those in the upcoming third
season plus stuff I kept his cards close
when indieWIRE asked him which films he
and his brother will be referencing this
time out but the final season 3 trailer
contains a few subtle clues Lucas for
example wears an outfit reminiscent of
the Karate Kid
one of the most blatant nods to an
iconic movie comes when Max 11 and Mike
take cover behind the counter in the
mall the shots are super similar to the
kitchen scene from Jurassic Park which
is of course an early 90s movie but
seeing as it's directed by Steven
Spielberg it's fair game that their four
brothers have made no secret of the fact
that they're heavily into Spielberg
naming et the extra-terrestrial Close
Encounters of the Third Kind and jaws as
big influences check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]